personne n'avait prévu de passer le
réveillon comme ça ni chailly ce
navigateur israéliens arrivés de grenade
ni les marins pêcheurs du port de grand
rivière mais voilà vers 19h hier soir le
voilier qui tentent d'entrer dans le
port se retrouvent couché sur la coque
et pour cause il n'y a que 10 cm d'eau
dans le port pour tous commence alors
une longue mais ça fait du bien que ce
soit fini vraiment du bien j'espère que
l'année prochaine sera un peu plus
facile
ces dix mains de ces nuits très longue
vous savez vous prenez juste une petite
mauvaise décision sans même y penser
et vous vous retrouvez dans cette
situation ce n'était pas en danger de
mort car ce n'était que le bateau mais
souvent vous verrez que les marins sont
attachés à leur bateau comme si c'était
une partie d'eux-mêmes avec la houle
impressionnante ici le bateau dit choi
ne serait sûrement pas en une seule
pièce s'il n'avait pas réussi à le
récupérer
on a t'il été sonnée par les cm environ
il n'a pas d'eau alors avec le jeune à
celui là le petit hall gill à 10 cm à 4
heures du matin la voiture avec ma tête
on a fait ce qu'on pouvait lui ne
pouvait pas bien voir pour bien
travailler pour mettre le bateau si donc
on a attendu que le jour se lève pour
continuer un tig le bateau du scar
jusqu'à commettre là ce problème
d'ensablement du port de grand rivière
il n'est pas nouveau une dragueuse mêmes
amarrés en permanence
seulement voilà elle est en panne depuis
trois mois malgré le marché attribué est
la seule autre machine similaire se
trouve au vauclin étant donné qu'il ya
déjà une mesure souvent créés en plus
une jos agrumes via où je pense qu'il va
respecter le marché qui lui a été
attribuée donc il viendra pas grand
vient donc la profession va prendre un
coup
ils vont rester là sur deux trois mois
et non
ça on va monter au créneau non content
de l'avoir aidé les marins pêcheurs se
sont ensuite occupé du navigateur une
solidarité qui a touché qu israéliens
les marins pêcheurs comprennent qu'on ne
peut pas y arriver tout seul ils ont un
sens de la communauté que je n'ai jamais
vraiment rencontré autant chez les
autres agde et ils vont au delà à l'ope
d'eux mêmes pour aider et shine ne sait
pas encore comment il va pouvoir sortir
du port il se souviendra longtemps de
son réveil en 2018 en martinique